[Music]
you're good friends with Snoop Dogg you
guys are pals I like him a lot he's a
great guy okay I think we have a picture
of you two guys hanging out together
what was on that's basically I think
that's the cover of his new album coming
out that was on his show and we
pretended to be me and I pretended to be
him the only problem with Snoop Dogg and
you know him right
sure okay where are we hang all the time
well when yeah when you're with Snoop
Dogg for any period of time just for a
half hour let's say you're interviewing
them or walk around the room with them
he proves that you can get secondhand
smoke yes because you go home hi yeah so
you've gotten hot first of all I've
experienced this when snoop comes here
and he now he's Snoop lion unless he's
back to sucking blood yeah but just
forget his name right but he was in the
he came here and he smoked so much pot
that it filtered out by being high and
he was getting well and II was already
high in the audience that's right yeah
the band actually straightened out
well it was a little tight for them yeah
exactly but I'm just curious so so
here's a question I have for you what is
it what is the course good lord what a
weak point you have thank you I don't
know why you come back cuz I'm such an
idiot
okay I don't they didn't call it pot
back in your day what did you mean my
day well come on back in the day you
know you're back in the day they didn't
call it what you call it jazz cigarettes
did you did you ask for some wacky
tabacky you ever get any of that you
know
cuckoo dust you're on a roll you're on a
roll yeah okay yeah no I'm just curious
back in the day I smoked it a few times
with my doctor I was worried I was these
doctors you get who are these doctors so
far this one I've heard about your
doctor take human growth hormone okay
professional doctors get some wacky
tabacky Enya I've got a strong handshake
yeah okay so what happened was I smoked
it a few times it was very enjoyable I
liked it but then I used to smoke a lot
of cigarettes I smoke you ever smoked no
so yeah I smoked three packs a day and I
had a heart attack in 1987 and the day I
got the heart attack I stopped smoking
right that was many many years ago so I
was afraid to ever go back to marijuana
again because I thought if I smoked
about one again I'd go back to
cigarettes you know sure that makes
sense so I never tried it again here's
my question you liked it but you can't
smoke it there's edible marijuana what
about that I don't know I got no I'm not
a cookie man I'm not a cookie man I've
heard you're a cookie man
wait a minute what about a pot brownie
have you had a pot brownie no why we
have one right here we have a pot
brownie I don't know and you know just
if you're interested this is it looks
like you just pick that up off the floor
I tell you what I did I heard that you
had never tried fo so I thought I'll
take a bite you take a bite you take a
bite all right sure what the heck
Jeff is this legal that we allowed to do
this what no it's not legal our
producers telling us it's not legal go
ahead and do it I don't care
LAPD's busy doing other things anyway
thanks for handling my food yeah I got
some you know you're gonna take in a
piece and handed it off you made sure
you touched every single piece man on
the floor what's been on the floor I got
rug in mine I don't think there's any
weeding that brownie oh we good clever
Andy
[Applause]
[Music]
this there sure isn't any in there just
keep eating Larry it's just our regular
brownie this is me and I never seen
again so quickly going going going
I like the straps
you